Hi.
In this problem, we're going
to look at random incidence
under Erlang arrivals.
First, let's parse
what that means.
In a Poisson process, remember,
the time between
arrivals, or the inter-arrival
time, is distributed as an
exponential random variable.
And random incidence for a
Poisson process refers to the
somewhat surprising result
that when you consider a
specific time, say, T-star,
then the length of the
inter-arrival interval that
contains that time T-star is
not distributed as an
exponential random variable.
It's actually distributed as an
Erlang random variable of
order 2 or it's distributed as
a sum of two exponential
random variables.
And the reason for
that is that it
comprises of two parts.
One is the time since the last
arrival until T-star, which is
exponentially distributed, and
the time from T-star until the
next arrival, which is also
exponentially distributed.
So that brings us to a review
of what Erlang random
variables are.
An Erlang random variable of
order k is just the sum of k
independent and identically
distributed
exponential random variables.
So to be more specific, if Ti
is an exponential random
variable with parameter lambda,
then if you take kiid
copies of Ti and add them up,
and call that Yk, then Yk is
an Erlang random variable
of order k.
And one other fact is that the
mean of Yk, the mean of an
Erlang random variable of order
k, is just k, the order,
over lambda, which is the rate
of the underlying exponential
random variables.
So as a consequence, if you have
an Erlang random variable
of order two and that random
variable also has a mean of
two over lambda, we can
interpret that random variable
as just being the sum of two
exponential random variables.
2 iid exponential random
variables, T1 and T2, where
each one takes exponential
with the rate in lambda.
OK, so in this problem now,
we're dealing with the random
incidence not under Poisson
processes, but under something
else, which we call here an
Erlang process with Erlang
arrival times.
So to be more specific, what
we're saying is that, instead
of inter-arrival time being
exponentially distributed, in
this process, and inter-arrival
time is actually
distributed as an Erlang random
variable of order 2
with mean 2 over lambda.
So to be explicit, this is no
longer a Poisson process.
It's some other process because
the inter-arrival
times are not exponential.
So let's make use of this fact
that we talked about earlier
because now we know that the
inter-arrival times of this
Erlang process are
Erlang order 2
with mean 2 over lambda.
But we know that that can just
be re-interpreted as a sum of
two simple exponentials, each
with parameter lambda.
So let's just draw another
picture and imagine that for
each of these arrivals, so say
we have three sample arrivals
in this Erlang process, we can
fill in, kind of, the gaps
between these with additional
arrivals.
And then think of each one of
these times as all being
exponential with parameter
lambda.
So this is a valid
interpretation because when we
connect these, these
inter-arrival times correspond
to the combination of two
inter-arrival times, which we
know we can split that into
just two exponentials.
So each one of these is an
exponential random variable.
And when you combine them, you
get an Erlang order of 2.
But the nice thing about this
is that if we look at this
diagram, it actually is just
exactly a Poisson process with
a rate lambda because
now, what we're
dealing with are exactly--
the inter-arrival times
are now exactly
exponential random variables.
And so this is in fact, now,
just a simple Poisson process.
And we can also just think of
it as we take the Poisson
process, and take every other
arrival, say, all the
even-numbered arrivals, and make
those corresponds to be
arrivals in the Erlang
process.
OK, so now let's think about
some specific time T-star.
We want to know what is the
distribution of the length of
this to be specific
inter-arrival interval that
T-star is in.
Well, what we can do is take it
down to the level of this
Poisson process and look
at it from there.
Well, we do that because, for
a Poisson process, we know
about random incidence for
Poisson processes.
And we know how to deal with
So let's think about this now.
Well, T-star is here.
And what we know from random
incidence for a Poisson
processes is that the length of
this inter-arrival interval
for the Poisson process,
we know that this is an
exponential plus
an exponential.
So combined, this is
Erlang order 2.
But that only covers
from here to here.
And what we want is actually
from here to there.
Well now, we tack on an extra
exponential because we know
that the inter-arrival times--
the time between this arrival
and that arrival in the
Poisson process is just
another exponential.
And now all of these are in
[INAUDIBLE] time intervals.
And they're all independent.
And so the time of this
inter-arrival interval in the
Erlang process is just going
to be the sum of three
independent exponentials
within the
underlying Poisson process.
And so to answer here is
actually, it's going to be an
Erlang of order 3.
Now this is one possible
scenario for
how this might occur.
Another scenario is actually
that T-star is somewhere else.
So let's draw this again.
And suppose now, in this case,
T-star landed between an even
numbered arrival in the Poisson
process and an odd
numbered arrival.
Now it could also arrive between
an odd numbered and an
even numbered arrival.
So it could be that T-star
is actually here.
Well, but in this case, it's
actually more or less the same
thing because now what we want
is the length of this entire
inter-arrival interval, which,
in the Poisson world, we can
break it down into random
incidence within this
interval, this inter-arrival
interval, which is two
exponentials, or an Erlang of
2, plus this interval, which
is just a standard inter-arrival
time, which is
another exponential.
So in this case as well, we
have the sum of three
independent exponential
random variables.
And so, in either case, we have
that the inter-arrival
time in the Erlang process
is an Erlang of order 3.
And so the final answer is, in
fact, that the inter-arrival
for random incidence under these
Erlang-type arrivals is
an Erlang of order 3.
OK, so in this problem we looked
at the random incidence
under a different type of an
arrival process, not Poisson,
but with Erlang random
variables.
But we used the insight that
Erlang really can be
re-interpreted as the sum of
independent and identically
distributed exponential
random variables.
And exponential random variables
can be viewed as one
way of interpreting and viewing
a Poisson process.
And so by going through those
steps, we were able to use
what we know about random
incidence under Poisson
processes to help us solve
this problem of random
incidence its Erlang arrivals.
So I hope that was helpful.
And I'll see you next time.